(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Here in this Saint Petersburg
apartment building, you
can find Tatiana Subbotina,
better known as The Green Screen Grandma.
A retired engineer, Tatiana
has attracted a following
creating some unique content for YouTube.
(yelling)
Tatiana's channel has
almost 30,000 subscribers
and over two and a half million views.
Surprising because Tatiana
is completely self taught.
Once she graduated from puppetry,
Tatiana's channel really took off.
There was one video in particular
that really propelled her
to the national stage.
Despite her large and growing audience,
Tatiana doesn't see herself as a star.
A baby star now, but you
wanna be famous, don't you?
(upbeat music)